so this is a sample of ruthenium sponge
so the ruthenium metal has been
precipitated from a very fine particles
so here we'll just open the box and
rather ashamed that I made the big
mistake about the name of ruthenium I
thought it referred to somewhere in
middle Europe perhaps in Czechoslovakia
whereas ruthenium actually comes from
ruthenia which is the latin translation
for the country that is now called
russia and in fact the element ruthenium
was first discovered in russia in the
city of kazan why would that be a
particular cause of shame view
well because my father was born in
Russia and therefore to get something
connected with Russia wrong is a bit
embarrassing the ruthenium is a very
very reactive metal especially when it's
formed in this very fine sponge type
material ruthenium was actually
discovered relatively early in the
middle of the 19th century there is some
discussion whether in fact the Swedish
chemist Berzelius analyzed something
that contained ruthenium and missed it
or not but I'm not quite sure about that
but the reason why interested in this is
because I did my doctorate with a
supervisor and if you look at his
supervisor and then that's there and go
back one supervisor after another you
eventually get to the Swedish chemist
Berzelius who was my
great-great-great-great graduate
supervisor and in fact that most of the
chemists now working in the world were
related to just a few pioneering
chemists in the 18th century
so the ruthenium is very very finely
divided and if I tip it you can see in
the bottom of the vial very fine powders
but again because of the particle size
this is really dark very black very nice
sample everything and very useful for
for catalytic chemistry it is as a
catalyst that ruthenium is particularly
famous
ruthenium itself if you look at the lump
of a metal is a sort of silvery color
this is a sample of ruthenium as a
catalyst now because it's an expensive
metal the ruthenium is just distributed
as a very thin layer on silica silica is
like sand and you can see that this
finely divided ruthenium looks black and
they're very finely divided so it has a
large surface area so the molecules can
come in and react it and my students
were using this catalyst to react a
organic compound that's one with carbon
hydrogen and to get it to react with
more hydrogen and so they lent me this
catalyst so I could show it to you there
are other ruthenium catalysts which
dissolve in the solution that you're
trying to get the reaction to go and
there's a very famous catalyst named
after the American chemist Bob Grubbs
who won the Nobel Prize about four years
ago and his catalyst does a reaction
which most people even kept some
chemists have not heard of which is
called metathesis in which double bonds
between two carbon atoms are broken and
joined together in a different way and
you can use this from all sorts of
things you can make plastics out of oils
you can make new sorts of wax you can
make a really great sort of wax that has
oxygen atoms in it and if you use this
for candles then the oxygen atoms make
fragrance molecules dissolve much better
than in ordinary wax so you can have a
Christmas candle which when you light it
smells of Christmas pudding or smells of
alcohol or vinegar and vanilla or
whatever spice you want and you can't do
that with an ordinary catalyst or
ordinary wax
but this ruthenium catalysts opens out
all sorts of things so that's why he got
the Nobel Prize the other reason why the
Nobel Prize cuz he made nice smelling
candles no he got the Nobel Prize
because he invented the catalysts that
opened up all sorts of reactions that
otherwise couldn't be done Bob Grubbs
compound has ruthenium and his is the
most widely used and it's now used in a
whole series of industrial processes
this is another compound of ruthenium
which you can see it's rather a nice red
color and it's um has the rather and
romantic name of ruthenium bippy three
times or chemists who use it call it
Ruby P and the point about this compound
is that it absorbs light well and it's
very stable you can shine light on it
very intense light for a long time the
compound doesn't decompose it doesn't
change but what it can do is when you
shine light is that you can move
electrons around inside the compound and
this compound and once like it are being
used by people to try and capture the
light from the Sun capture solar energy